voilà là on est dans le futur on revient
en arrière maintenant effectivement
souvent en regardant les journaux
télévisés ou d'autres magazines
d'information vous avez aperçu sur des
images d'archivés dans le coin à droite
là le sigle ina institut national de
l'audiovisuel c'est la quête engrangé
toute la mémoire film et du 20e siècle
et cette mémoire va encore augmenter
s'agrandir car une loi oblige désormais
non plus le seul service public a déposé
ses documents
mais l'ensemble des sociétés
audiovisuelles nationale par ailleurs
les chercheurs ont désormais sont
désormais autorisés à consulter ces
archives qui contiennent de véritables
trésors et qui sont notre mémoire
audiovisuelle enquête patricia charnley
christian hutin
c'est notre patrimoine audiovisuel qui
est réuni ici sur un seul écran de micro
ordinateurs
les chercheurs peuvent consulter les
milliers d'heures de programmes radio et
télé qui constituent les archives actuel
de linars les nouveaux moyens donnés par
la loi à l'institut national de
l'audiovisuel 54 millions de francs de
budget d'investissement vont enfin
permettre à la france de constituer une
bibliothèque d'un autre type depuis très
longtemps une grande exploitation des
images d'archivés de télévision comme
source de programme
ils ont là il s'agit d'avoir une
activité complémentaire supplémentaires
qui existe beaucoup dans les pays anglo
saxons pour ouvrir l'ensemble de ses 850
leader depuis l'origine et plus
spécialement à partir du 1er janvier 95
à la recherche historique scientifique
en général à cette date en effet c'est
de la mise en oeuvre du dépôt légal
toutes les sociétés nationales de
programme dont les chaînes privées
devront verser leurs oeuvres à l'ina des
techniques de pointe permettent déjà de
conserver les documents
ceux ci sont systématiquement recopier
les programmes radio sont mémorisés sur
disquette dès l'année prochaine les
cassettes télé seront compressées survie
ce que numérique
tout est fait pour bien conserver nos
trésors dans le cadre fleuri
d'armenonville journée de la vie cycle
est journée de l'élégance journée de la
femme devant le jury c'est le défilé des
concurrentes et l'amérique ne serait pas
l'amérique qui s'échappe ou n'étaient
que des chapeaux outre atlantique la
mode et la pâtisserie font bon ménage
christian dior a décidé les jupes seront
courtes elles ne paraissent pas à vrai
dire si courte que ça et pourtant ces 40
cm du sol ont provoqué dans le monde les
commentaires les plus passionnés autour
de ce qu'on appelait la pompe dior et
dans cette présentation privée vous
voyez mesdames aux jambes réapparaître
après être resté des années cacher je
pense que l'élément principal de cette
mode et la jeunesse et surtout un retour
à des tendances jusque là un peu oublié
c'est à dire la simplicité le naturel la
souplesse il fallait pour la france une
politique de la mémoire audiovisuelle
c'est fait il faudra dans l'avenir
ouvrir ses archives au plus grand nombre
car dans ses placards et stocker une
partie de notre histoire